this video is sponsored by mobile
legends adventure hey
are you a gamer great but mobile legend
sounds like the game for you
what more can you ask for than a
stress-free idol rpg for adventurers
which includes mysterious dungeons mazes
less complicated gameplay for a more
enjoyable experience
you want stress-free idle gameplay
mobile legends has that
you can fight how you like you can have
fully automated combat or you can
manually control and command your own
strategies to win the battle
there are abundant rewards even if
you're offline all you need to do is tap
the screen occasionally to get the
variety of prize pools
and don't forget about the 70 unique
heroes they can use for various team
compositions to play through all the
strategic
dungeons to go through your adventure
and look they know who they're making
this for it's got all the manga art
styles just for all the dirty weaves
like you
hey kids have you been a good boy for
santa no
that's fine because mobile legends is
saving christmas
right now they are doing special
christmas events that is the biggest
carnival in the history of mobile
legends
including the christmas high the icy
brawl and the snowball fight
there are tons of rewards and gifts that
you can get right now just by logging in
and participating
what more could you want for christmas
sorry mum i don't need another pair of
dirty socks
i have mobile legends adventure so
what are you waiting for click the link
in the description to give it a go and
you can also use my special key on
screen to redeem a premium
5 star summon roll you have to reach
level 10 to redeem it so get it while
it's hot
and with that said let's get on with the
video
guys i have a confession to make there's
a secret i've been keeping from you all
that i'm
ashamed to admit but we're close enough
right this is a safe place
i feel it's time you knew the person i
really was i play
league of legends i know i know i'm
sorry okay i don't want to shatter the
image of this decent respectful human
being that you have at me but i just
needed to get this off my chest okay
i have such a love-hate relationship
with league or a hate-hate relationship
with league or just a
hate relationship i just hate league
what the [ __ ] do i still keep playing
because no matter how much i think i've
moved on from
it there's been one single reason i keep
coming
back
i love esports i barely play league
anymore but the esports scene is so good
i inevitably keep up with it and because
of this
every so often i get the urge to boot up
a game myself and
every time i do within one game i get
reminded why i'd rather watch a group of
five people hating their own life rather
than experiencing it myself
it's something i'm so into i even
attended the 2018 world finals to cheer
on my european representatives where i
witnessed a miracle happen in front of
me
kda debuted and it made lee cool for
like a week
and then i watched my team get
absolutely demolished of course this
isn't just limited to league
evo cs go dota 2 not you overwatch
league go back in your own corner there
are so many magical moments i've seen in
esports for games i don't even play and
i think it's
[ __ ] great okay we get a gig but
what has this got to do with anime for
the longest time i've wanted an esports
anime given that a lot of esports is
already riddled with anime-esque plot
lines and there's so much promotional
material that is heavily anime inspired
and given how hype we know traditional
sports anime can be
translating esports into anime seems
like a match made in gamer girl heaven
but competitive gaming and anime is
almost non-existent in fact
games are normally used as a set piece
for a more casual affair
or is just used as a base for another
[ __ ] isekai world
the gamers in anime are like pro gamers
but
without the pro so what does that even
make them
gamers oh ew gross
get that [ __ ] out of here oh give me a
second one throw up my secret labs
gaming chair but a few years ago china
said it's cool japan
hold my razor death outer elite gaming
mouse
as close as we come to an esports anime
so far and yes i know it's not
technically an anime but a chinese
animation or
donghua for all you hip kids out there
but shut up and let me click bait
alright originating from a web novel
that has now been adapted into a manga
live-action series and of course anime
season 2 of the anime just finished
airing but with the amount of shows
airing the season and the 2020 anime fan
experience being
not watching anime it doesn't really
surprise me that no one even seems to
know this show [ __ ] exists
so i'm gonna talk about it the king's
avatar takes place in a world where
people play games for money
yeah mom it's really a thing now i'm
serious just do do the google thing
glory is one of the most popular games
in the world being a super duper awesome
game where everyone's friendly and no
one calls their mother a [ __ ] for
picking yasuo and going 0-5 in the first
five minutes our protagonist is one of
the oldest and most decorated players
the game has ever seen but at the grand
daddy age of 25 which i'm
absolutely serious is really old for
esports athletes and unwilling to take
part in any of his team's promotional
marketing even though he's still one of
the best players in the game he doesn't
provide a lot of financial benefits to
his organization
so his organization literally did a pro
gamer move
and fired him which i'm gonna be honest
wasn't very poggers of them that
wasn't pogba's at all man like come on
that's not an epic gamer moment that's
an
epic fail moment what the [ __ ] am i
saying being forced to resign and stay
away from the professional league for at
least a year he gets a job at an
internet cafe and so begins his new
journey as he starts a completely new
account and climbs his way up the ranks
once more building up a new team of
gamer girls and not arsenal as he plans
his epic comeback on a bigger stage of
gaming
from the basic plot description you may
think this sounds like yet another video
game anime with the no people attacking
is stopping noob after noob and
well you're absolutely right i mean the
guy's name
literally translates to battle god for
[ __ ] sake what do you think is gonna
happen when he starts a fresh account
this guy no pog chump he's a pog chap
[ __ ] me that was an awful line while i
keep that in the script basically the
show is what would happen if you had
faker
diego or any legendary player start off
in the lowest ranks of their respective
game and grind their way back
up it's a [ __ ] smurfing show it's
road to challenger anime edition alright
but if you know me you know i'm not a
guy who settles for your bog standard
pal
fancy anime
and what makes this show interesting for
people like me is the additional element
of esports which is not something we've
seen in anime before
because the biggest problem i find with
a lot of video game anime is
how do you properly introduce stakes
into an anime based entirely on a video
game like okay
you could be dunking on the biggest
douchebag of all time you could be
taking part
some sick ass online events [ __ ] man you
could even be fighting for
nationals but no matter if it's sao ggo
alo cs go or raid shadow legends it's
hard to get invested in the outcome of
the game because at the back of my mind
i'm just thinking
yo it's just a game bro and anyone that
ever uses the excuse is just a game is a
horrible human being
and it's lazy it's only a game lazy
human being to borrow some shows like
loc horizon which just has insanely
interesting world building and mechanics
the default answer is just to make some
nice little wholesome slice of life but
the whole point is just to have fun with
your friends and be okay
casual gamer alternatively just go well
if you die in the game you die in real
life
or you know just make the game between
east kai world where if you die in the
world you die
in the games that you die in real life
but the beauty of this taking place in
the world of esports is that
these are actual stakes we see in the
real world this isn't just a high school
team where union mates piss about in
your local land tournament it's the real
professional esports scene
not only is your pride online but so are
player contracts and winnings worth
hundreds of thousands or even millions
of dollars and it does a good job
showing that a pro
isn't just about being good at the game
some of the more interesting subplots
outside of the game itself
just seeing the politics behind the
esports scene because there's more to
creating a professional team than just
getting good players you need to think
about marketing and hype public
perception and reputation
signing big names isn't just about
getting high skill players big names
bring with them big followings and aside
from winning there are more ways to grow
a dedicated fan base
at the end of the day it doesn't stop
reminding us that esports the teams and
the brands
are well a business what i'm saying is
it's nice that we found an in-between
from cute anime girls do gamer girl
things and yo
hold up i gotta land this sick combo or
i die in the game where i die in real
life the show obviously has a good
understanding of the competitive gaming
scene especially when compared to other
anime like remember when kirito was a
god at seo simply because he was a beta
player well
there's a bit more that goes into that
here of course there's a highlight on
apm and raw game mechanics but what i
especially like is the emphasis on game
knowledge anyone who's gotten into
competitive video games knows that at
the highest level there are plenty of
mechanically skilled players and what
really separates the good from the
absolute best
are people's depth of game knowledge
which is shown as an equally important
reason of why the protagonist is so op
because he's amassed so much knowledge
from playing the same game for 10 years
not only that but king's avatar backs it
up with pretty decent production values
for the longest time it felt like any
animated show that came out of china was
a few years from what we'd see here in
japan but king's avatar was one of the
first shows that proved the potential of
chinese animation it isn't god tier
ufotable or bones level yet but in my
opinion it matches up to some of the
better anime out there
the series sports some pretty impressive
in-game fight scenes at times it's just
too bad that there's only so much you
can do to make mouse clicking and
keyboard tapping hype like
there would be times where this epic
anime battle would be happening on
screen and then they would cut to the
real life characters and it kind of felt
like
[Music]
i'd actually say the biggest
disappointment i've had with the series
thus far is
the actual esport of this esport anime
wait what since glory is based on an mmo
and not a moba like league or a fighting
game or an fps we follow our main team
as they grind their characters to max
level and honestly it sometimes felt
just like that a grind because that's
what mostly happens in season one
look i know we have to build up the team
and the characters before we enter the
league and everything but i'm gonna be
real here i don't care how many noobs
you stomp i don't care how many records
you set on your new server
i just want to hear an overly excited
korean man shouting
in season 2 we've at least reached the
professional level where all the pro
players are interacting with each other
but the teams haven't even fully
assembled yet or reached max level
so while it is nice to see the esports
element being put into a game series for
once it hasn't yet
felt like an esports anime i remember
watching season one a few years ago and
saying this wasn't an esports anime
this was an anime with esports in it at
least
that's what i would be saying if we
didn't have the ova
series for me by far the biggest
highlight so far is a three episode over
here that takes place between season one
and two
and as an esports fan watching it it was
everything
i wanted the arc details an all-star
type exhibition event between some of
the top players in the league and it
pretty much encapsulates the hype and
appeal of a big esporting event
even though it was just an exhibition it
was cathartic to see all the pros and
the teams that were built up
playing on a stage far bigger than any
of your typical sports anime
even if it was just technically for
pride it was surprising how well it
captured the energy of a big event like
this with pretty insane animation in
some of the fights
signing off with the narrative climax
that made me stamp down and say
yes this is exactly why i wanted an
esports anime the only problem is
it just made me impatient for the story
to get to a point where we get to see
teams actually competing again on a
stage like this in actual high-stakes
matches
because if this is just a taste of how
good things could be
it has the potential to stand up to the
hype of some of our favorite sports
anime but
as it stands we are still grinding to
get to that point look i'm going to be
completely honest
to most people this is just going to be
another slightly above average power
fantasy anime with no difference from
most isekai or magic harem high schools
but
if you are someone like me who loves
keeping up with esports and has been
looking for that non-existent anime to
scratch that
itch then i highly recommend you give
king's avatar a chance
to me it's not always about finding the
best shows because part of the reason i
got into anime was so i can find
niche stories and settings that i
couldn't find anywhere else and in this
case if japan wasn't going to make it
then i'm more than happy to look outside
the esports scene in japan is still very
small competitive gaming takes a back
seat to how big the mobile gaming
industry is here unless you're a
self-proclaimed
diamond ranked gacha game player like me
also known as i have a big [ __ ]
problem
it's unlikely we would have gotten an
esports anime so it's times like these
i'm glad that not only has anime got
more international but so has its
influence barring the biggest surprise
that nice force manual hasn't come out
of korea yet the scene in china is still
massive with the infrastructure now
mirroring more traditional sports
with league teams having their own
dedicated stadiums in their home cities
which is
crazy to think about so it's no wonder
an animated series like this had the
chance to be produced there
currently season one and two of kings
avatar is available right here on
youtube officially subbed so
unfortunately you're gonna have to look
elsewhere for the ova series though
so in conclusion stop playing league of
legends
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you again to mobile legends for
sponsoring me today
if any of what you saw looked
interesting to you you can click the
link in the description to download it
today
and with that said thank you very much
to
alpha basil box lfo joe augustine
mike elfin payne patchett and everyone
else my patreon for helping to support
me on this month
alright guys let's have a quick chat so
i know my upload schedule recently has
been
a little bit whack it's uh not been the
greatest and there is a reason for that
i'm trying this new thing called um
getting ahead of the schedule so don't
worry if you think you've seen a little
less of me
i'm actually trying to get a proper
upload schedule of minimum of two videos
a month and once i
make a backlog i can focus on making it
a bit more than that or maybe just use
that extra time to focus on bigger
projects
so yeah that's kind of the solution i'm
trying to work on to fix my workflow
which i've talked on in previous videos
so yeah don't worry if you've seen a
little bit less of me recently
anyway that's it for me though i've been
giggup and i will see you all
next time